(techno music)
- We will see a transgender Olympian,
in my lifetime.
Someone who is out and
authentic with their identity
and still competing in
sports at a high level,
because now it's possible.
My name is Chris Mosier
and I'm the first transgender man
to make a men's US National Team.
My sport is sprint duathlon.
And duathlon is run, bike, run.
When I first started
competing after transition,
No one really thought
that I would do well.
Everyone pretty much just wrote me off
because they looked at me
and thought, "Oh, he's a trans guy.
"There's no way that he
can compete against men."
Hearing people say that
really motivated me
to work harder, to learn more,
to be more dedicated to my training
and try to be the strongest
competitor that I can be.
Even though I made Team USA,
I was ineligible to
compete at the world level
because of the International
Olympic Committee policy
which stated transgender
athletes needed to have
a full lower surgery
performed in order to qualify.
Adding an extra body part
is not going to make me
a faster runner or a stronger cyclist.
They just needed an athlete
with a name and a face,
someone who was actually
being impacted by this policy
to look at it and to say this isn't right.
The International Olympic
Committee changed their policy
for transgender athletes
and no longer have
the same restrictions they had before.
I was so thrilled when the
policy was changed for myself,
but I was even happier that
the policy is now changed
for everybody who comes after me.
I will not be competing in Rio
because duathlon is not an Olympic sport,
but I am so excited to some day
see a transgender Olympian compete
on behalf of our country.
What used to be the
ceiling is now the floor.